take a look at this surfer maya cabera
is used to staring down the face of
massive waves but this one was a monster
at 73 and a half feet high it broke the
record for the biggest wave ever surfed
by a woman now with her new children's
book maya and the beast the brazilian
daredevil aims to inspire others it
tells the story of a little girl who
won't give up trying to surf big waves
and draws on gabriela's experience
trying to achieve her dreams maya good
morning good morning thanks for having
me so what made you want to write a
children's book
oh um
pandemic hit and i was often walking my
dogs in the forest that's all i did for
a while and the title came up on my mind
and i was like hmm that could be fun you
know i'm going to have time on my hands
because the world is going a little
crazy
and mayan the beast
um title and then
work and then work i had no idea how to
create a children's books but it's a
really good book what do you want
children to take away after they read
this book
um
i want to see what they take away you
know i mean of course from my story it's
resilience it's courage it's finding
your passion it's
listening to your inner voice which i
think comes with the shell interaction
and how
you know you have this voice that is
actually inside you that tells you that
you can while you have all those voices
outside that tells you that you can't
that that is crazy
so finding that grabbing on to that and
realizing that there's going to be a lot
of obstacles but you can you can achieve
whatever you put your mind into adults
need to hear that too that's for sure
and the beast it seems represents not
just in the it's the wave in the book
it's the way these can be whatever it is
that you're trying to overcome exactly
exactly and sometimes you know i like to
think that like the beast you know for
the town and for a lot of people is this
monster and this thing that nobody wants
anything to do with but maya realized
that for her the beast was this
beautiful wave that she wanted
everything to do with yeah so we're all
different yeah and then in the book you
can see the illustration it shows uh she
has an inhaler
yes and that's something you you've
talked about that you have asthma how
has that impacted
you and why was it so important to add
that detail yeah i grew up with asthma
and um
swimming was very important for me
actually sports was very important for
me to develop my lungs and to keep
working
on my health and
you know asthma made me have limitations
and i dealt with those limitations my
whole career and especially in the
beginning when miasma was more
was stronger than it is today so asthma
was my limitation that in the end you
know because
asthma dealt with breeding and i went
into a path that
often i'm underwater without breath
it became kind of my strength you know i
turned that around where you know i knew
what it was like to be out of breath
and so there was a comfort there that i
could translate once i went into the
waves and i was underwater and i
couldn't breed
i had that since i was born yeah i want
you to take us on the board
in the water
riding a wave like that 73 and a half
foot monster like what is going through
your mind when you are
in the middle of dominating a wave this
size ooh
um that's the beauty of it not much is
going through my mind really i'm living
in the moment and i'm like having to
adjust and adapt to everything that's
happening around me which is a lot you
know the way that the wave is shaping
the line i want to take
how i want to make a critical ride but
also be safe and end the ride and and
the channel and be picked up by my
partner so i'm
living in the moment which i find is one
of my favorite parts of big wave surfing
because it is so intense and demands so
much focus that you're in the flow
there's no way
out you know your your instincts are so
alive and you're really working with the
knowledge you have created before how do
you do this though i mean you almost
lost your life in 2013 after having an
experience like that how are you able to
still be in the moment as you put it
well the moments afterwards were
horrible
but then i accepted that
you know life is not always easy and and
life is not always you know winning and
i went through a four-year period of
spine surgeries failed spine surgeries
and traumatized and it was hard to go
back to my sport but also at the same
time
it was going to be harder to give up on
everything i had worked towards you know
i was 26 i was an established big wave
surfer and i had just found the new well
it had just been discovered the new
frontier of our sport which was nasa
report to go and to walk away from that
to me was crazy it was crazier than keep
working maya gubera thank you so much
for joining us maya and the beast goes
on sale tomorrow
we will be right back